[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous j'espère que vous n'êtes pas trop
déprimé après l'analyse de nos chers
scientifiques qui nous on voit là un
petit peu mis un coup de froid sur ce
plateau
j'ai tout seul mais bon voilà alors on
se demande un cheikh alexis qu'attendu
des promesses du président macron il
avait dit encore quatre à six semaines
d'efforts on tiens c'était il ya six
semaines aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous
sur le front de la crise oui alors c'est
vrai pas autant essayer d'en rire
effectivement parce que sinon c'est la
déprime qui nous guette d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron ira demain dans un
service de pédopsychiatrie pour voir les
enfants qui souffrent beaucoup
des mesures de confinement qui ont été
imposées alors c'est vrai il ya ainsi
semaine il nous disait dans quatre à six
semaines vous allez voir on va assouplir
ces mesures bon on est maintenant il ya
six semaines dans le futur
l'épidémiologiste en chef fait que nous
sommes toujours sous des mesures de
confinement de couvre feu avec des
mesures ubuesque comme le port du masque
sur la plage alors que la communiquer la
part dans la contamination extérieure
est très faible avec l'interdiction de
consommer d'alcool sur la voie publique
ou même de mettre de la musique
amplifiée sur la voie publique
allez savoir des fois que le virus m
danser tout ça fait qu'on continue avec
l'absurde east hants autoritaire ça ça
n'a pas changé
ce qui a changé c'est peut-être les
promesses sur la vaccination là il ya eu
plusieurs quoi quand on se rappelle
astrazeneca évidemment avec ses
thrombose veineuse quatre enquêtes sont
en cours puisqu'il est le cas de décès
suspects de personnes à ces jeunes qui
avaient reçu une première dose
d'astrazeneca
depuis les français rechignent un peu à
se faire vacciner avec astrazeneca alors
l'objectif est de vacciner 10 millions
mi avril apparemment il est atteint 20
millions mi mai et 30 millions de
français à la mi juin
mais pour ça il va falloir recevoir des
doses et les doses il s'agit bien de
johnson & johnson
malheureusement on apprend aujourd'hui
que le vaccin est lui aussi provoque
quelques soucis et donc a été mis en
pause par l'autorité de santé américaine
et que l'entreprise johnson & johnson va
donc décaler ses livraisons à l'europe
donc encore une fois ça paraît compliqué
de tenir les dates de vaccination
et puis il ya une promesse qui n'en est
pas une mais
finalement un chiffre fatidique tragique
les cent mille morts qui risque
d'arriver dans les jours qui viennent et
ça emmanuel macron aimerait tout faire
pour ne pas avoir à le supporter à
l'assumer
ça va être l'objet bien sûr de une
séquence de communication de plus on en
a vu une de séquences de communication
qui a bien fait rire en même temps que
pleurer un c'est un peu la base de cette
gestion de crise c'est les vols depuis
le brésil
alors dimanche les vols depuis le brésil
selon le ministre des transports a été
contrôlé il y avait très peu de gens qui
arrivaient et on ne pouvait pas de toute
façon arrêter ces vols à cause du droit
international tout le monde sait jamais
quand même les variants brésiliens ont
l'air assez agressif
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas faire des
quarantaines comme dans d'autres pays ou
bien supprimer tout simplement les vols
pendant un temps et non impossible nous
disait ton et bien aujourd'hui jean
castex devant les députés a dit que
c'est bon on va pouvoir suspendre filles
du droit international après tout quand
on veut on peut
c'est ça gérer une crise de manière
politique c'est ce que n'ont pas fait
les membres du gouvernement depuis le
début de cette crise armée en même temps
des efforts ont quand même été fait sur
les promesses de réindustralisation
notamment avec la production de neubau
sur le sol national
alors production de doses l'encore aime
les vaincrons a joué sur les mots sur
ses comptes officiels sur les réseaux
sociaux il parlait de produire produire
produire avec les images de ces petites
bouteilles sur les lignes de production
il ne s'agit pas de produire les vaccins
mais d'embouteiller les vaccins dont
qu'il aurait dû mettre en bouteille est
embouteillée embouteillée ouf la connaît
flacco nef la connaît puisque les les
produits actifs ne sont pas produits sur
le territoire
elles sont simplement en bouteille pour
qu'on puisse avoir les doses donc il
s'agit simplement là dans une petite
pirouette pour expliquer que finalement
ça y est on va produire alors on
pourrait dire que tout va bien sanofi
par exemple va ouvrir une nouvelle usine
tant mieux mais c'est à singapour encore
raté ça ne sera pas en france donc la
réindustrialisation sur le monde du
médical et et de la pharma ça ne vient
pas encore les promesses de lui aussi
parlons-en rappelez-vous au coeur de la
crise en 2020 on était carrément à
promettre 14 midi d'animations
supplémentaires puis on est passé à 2010
puis dix mille lits et les soignants
peine à voir venir ces nouveaux leaders
animations alors on bricole un avec des
réfectoires d'hôpitaux qui sont
transformés en salle de réanimation
on apprend aussi qu'en octobre une
nouvelle revalorisation salariale aura
lieu pour les soignants mais quand même
là encore on a l'impression que tout ça
est gérée à vue avec aucune vision
stratégique que fait françois bayrou
haut commissariat au plan on a
l'impression que monsieur bayrou et plus
préoccupés par la tenue des élections
régionales est de savoir s'il aurait pu
les décalés pour éviter une défaite
plutôt que par planifier la production
justement les masques qui devait être
produit en france ce n'est pas le cas
des médicaments mais autres et puis voir
comment sauver l'hôpital ou ce qu'il en
reste parce que aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que et bien oui le système de
santé français souffre des mesures
d'austérité qui ont été prises pendant
des années et dans ces conditions alexis
peut-on encore croire aux promesses de
réouverture un même partielle mi mai
pour les restaurants bars et lieux
culturels
alors vous savez l'adage en politique
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
veulent bien y croire alors libre à
chacun de croire ou non aux promesses
des malaises macron il se dessine quand
même un mode de gouvernement un basé sur
l'esbroufé la communication bat
derniéres beauf en date jeudi le chef de
l'état va présider un conseil sur
justement le calendrier de réouverture
alors on se demande est ce bien le
moment n'est ce pas un peu prématuré
compte tenu de toutes ces nouvelles l'a
visiblement non il s'agit là de dire que
oui il est sur le terrain qu'il se bat
corps à corps avec ce virus avec aucun
superpouvoir malheureusement il est peut
aider c'est vrai est mal macron par
jean-michel bancaire qui vient d'être
qu'à contacter roselyne bachelot qui
sauvent et duco vide a pu réintégrer le
ministère de la culture mais quand même
ça fait un gouvernement bien mal en
point
et ça continue avec ses couacs de
vaccination que j'évoquais avec aussi
comment croire ce calendrier de
réouverture quand l'exécutif a tout fait
pour essayer de décaler les régionales
après l'été en septembre les commerçants
eux reste calme et attendre de savoir à
quelle sauce ils vont être ré ouverts ou
fermés pendant ce temps là on voit des
images d'angleterre ou d'ailleurs où les
gens se retrouvent au
tours de verre autour de moments
conviviaux alors que nous bien nous
sommes toujours à 19 heures enfermé et
nous avons la capacité de faire plus de
10 kilomètres au delà de chez nous
tandis que les avions pouvaient venir du
brésil jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors ça
reste quand même compliqué emmanuel
macron nous a demandé à certains
notamment aux artistes de chevaucher tig
rappelez-vous pour l'été apprenants on a
l'impression que c'est lui qui est tombé
du tigre qui est par terre et qui a bien
du mal à part à faire diversion pour
lancer finalement cette campagne pour sa
réélection qui va être empêtrés dans le
col vide et d'ailleurs la prochaine
diversion je me demande quand est-ce
qu'elle va arriver
vous savez c'est cette vidéo qu'il avait
promise de youtuber mcfly et carlito
vous répondre à des questions un peu
drôle c'est pas le moment non plus je
crois que cette vidéo est remise est
dans les cartons
merci avec six poulains et à propos des
régionales auxquelles vous faisiez
allusion aux émanations mais nationale
soutenue massivement tout à l'heure le
maintien enjoint de ces régionales et
départementales merci à vous